so it feels like there's two conflicts
that are uh very much tied together the
first is the violent conflict that's
playing out in ukraine this is the
russian forces versus ukrainian forces
uh the ukrainians have the support of
nato the united states uh and many other
allies uh the russians have you know
somewhat of a trump card and that
they're nuclearly armed and no one wants
to push them far enough to actually
execute that power
that's the violent conflict there's also
a financial war that seems to be taking
place which
was essentially over before it even
started once the european countries plus
the united states came together and they
levied what are unprecedented sanctions
against not only
the russian banks the central bank uh
their leadership but also what
essentially has been every single
wealthy person that even knows a
politician it seems like uh in russia
seems to be getting all of their assets
frozen etc like talk a little bit about
what your analysis is of the financial
war that's being levied and just how
effective that has been so far okay so
first the splash that's in the news
second the stuff that's behind it that's
actually more important and then the
third what's coming so
the splashes in the news is going after
the oligarchs in the 1990s a group of
people took advantage of the collapse of
the soviet system and grabbed assets for
themselves by on any number of means
very little of it was what we would
consider elite or what the russian law
would consider illegal because there
wasn't a lot of russian law then but it
was definitely unethical and they have
now become multi-billionaires uh this
first batch of oligarchs when putin came
in in the year 2000 he brought them to
heal
he made them a deal that if they stayed
completely out of politics he would not
go after their assets and so they've
there's been this truce between them for
the last 20 years
under putin he elevated a number of
people from his fsb days kgb days based
on who's doing the math
uh to take over large portions of the
russian economy and this includes things
like the defense industry uh gazprom
and which is the world's largest natural
gas company and rosneft which is the
world's second largest oil company and
these are all people who are not part of
that original group
these are people who are all in putin's
inner circle
so we're going after two different
groups of oligarchs here the ones that
are around putin totally worth it these
are people who have been with putin
bolted to the hip with every single
policy he's done for 20 years these
people should be brought down
the other people the folks that have
been there since the 1990s i don't mean
to suggest that they're kinder gentler
folks i mean they are robber barons at
best but going after them just makes you
feel good because they have very little
influence over putin so we're talking
here about melons scooping the entire
core out of the russian economy by going
after the leadership but
one group is not going to affect the war
whatsoever and that's that first group
in the 90s they're the ones who have
most of their assets overseas so they're
the ones who are actually vulnerable to
what's going on
now behind that
we didn't just sanction a bunch of
companies and people we sanctioned the
russian central bank
and we don't think of how important the
central bank is in systems because we
always assume it's a neutral actor in
the background that maybe messes around
with interest rates and bond purchases
and that's about it but they are the
primary connectivity point between any
economy and the rest of the world one of
the thousands reasons that i'm not a big
fan of bitcoin is it assumes that the
central banks a will empower it and b
will do nothing to impede it and that's
clearly not true and in the case of the
russian central bank they can no longer
deal with any entity in any of these
countries and access any currencies that
are dollars euros yen one australian
dollars canadian dollars taiwanese
dollars and i'm sure i've met swiss
francs i'm sure i've left out a bunch
so
anything that the bank tries to do
anywhere cannot use any of those normal
channels and so among other things that
denied the russians access to some 90 of
their currency reserves that means that
when they sell oil somebody has to like
physically do a transfer in a third
party and fly the money into moscow this
is not a tenable situation we tried
doing some version of this for iran and
it was crushing but we've never done it
to an economy this bigger this
holistically
and then what's coming
we have a number of sanctions against
russia it's the most sanctioned country
in history now actually has more
sanctions on it than all other countries
and all other time frames throughout
human history
the europeans are now talking about an
open ban
on all sales of russian crude
not
just to the europeans themselves because
all that would do is shift the pain
they're talking at the beginning of the
process of talking about making sure
that russian crude can't make it to
market anymore that would mean among
other things blocking ships from going
in and out of the baltic sea probably
the scagger at and probably blocking
ships going in and out of the black sea
probably through the turkish straits
now how the russians would respond to
that would be really interesting but if
the blockades are further back from
russian ports the russians militarily
can't do anything about it
so we're looking here at removing four
to five million barrels a day of crude
production from the world that is more
than enough to guarantee an energy
induced depression that is global in
scale and the crazy thing is we might
even get there without an official
sanction because insurance companies are
not allowing ships to go into these
ports the ports are shallow so they
can't take super tankers and then run it
to china so either you get this daisy
chain of dozens of mid-sized vessels
that are going to be loading onto a
super tanker inside of a nato port and
expecting that nato is not going to do
anything about it
or they just close the straight together
one way or another we are headed for a
very interesting year
so we'll get to commodities in one
second but i want to uh talk about this
central bank kind of sanction that you
mentioned sure which is uh it's one
thing to say hey you cannot transact
right if i said hey peter central bank
you're not allowed to transact uh in
these certain currencies or in these
other uh
other organizations
there's an added piece though where we
essentially have frozen or confiscated
the central bank reserves as well and
that to me feels like it is uh today a
footnote given how complex the situation
is and how um kind of uh uh just
mind-boggling everything
but it has massive ramifications across
many countries over the next you know 50
to 100 years what is your thoughts
around the actual freezing and
confiscation of another country's
central bank reserves that just happen
to not be within their border
let me put it to you from the point of
view of an outsider so here we've got
the united states who has been moving
down a path towards isolationism for 30
years and it just wakes up one day
decides that it wants to get involved in
the ukrainian russian situation
uh it's been removing troops from the
middle east it's been removing troops
from asia it's been removing troops from
europe
we when biden was elected we were at the
low point for international involvement
since
reconstruction we had fewer troops
stationed abroad that since
reconstruction so you know we're at 150
year low right now
and now we're telling people that they
can't use the dollar
or any currency
everyone who thought that the american
retreat was going to give rise to a
multi-polar world in which the united
states had minimal power really hadn't
been paying attention to how the world
works
to have a global currency the first
thing you have to be sure of is that the
country that issues currency has to
really not care about what happens with
it every single day because if they're
going to manipulate the currency in
order to achieve trade advantages then
nobody's going to want it in addition it
has to be you know sufficiently deep
full of liquidity in order to work
there's only one country that fits that
criteria there's only one country that's
fit that criteria since 1945 and it's
certainly not china
and people are discovering now countries
are discovering now
that if you want to be part of that
system
there are certain things you can and
cannot do
invading countries that for whatever
reason the united states should not be
invaded makes the list
and so i would say that the the biggest
panic the biggest damage that we are
seeing from the ukraine war outside of
ukraine obviously is in china because in
one month the russians have pulled back
the blinders on what has been a 50-year
strategic program the idea that china
can have the global power with american
sponsorship with american indifference
that it can take taiwan that it can
intimidate japan that can dominate all
of east asia and yet not suffer
economically at all it was always
ridiculous but now it's been shown to
just be absolutely stupid
now the question moving forward of
course is what's the next thing the
united states is going to care about and
considering how erratic our politics
have been for the last 15 years
that's a tough question but it's
something that every single country that
trades now has to obsess about if they
want to continue doing anything along
the lines that they thought they could
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time